It is a mutual understanding
of what the material gives us
and how we can build it.
I mean, we don't pronounce the words, but
we feel them while building up the story
and while building up the scenes.
Every eye flick, every head shake,
they all convey emotion.
Baz came up with an expression
which he used called poetic glue.
It’s basically shorthand for layering extra
information visually on top of the picture.
So we see the collage of different
headlines to add extra information
to give to the audience without adding time.
The way that world wide audiences
have responded to Top Gun: Maverick
has been far beyond anything
that the cast and crew dreamed of.
So thank you for watching and
I'm thrilled you enjoyed the movie.
Working with the actors performances
and finding that balance between light and dark,
comedy and drama.
And then finding and shaping the
sequences and the dialogue in the scenes
was such a rewarding experience.
One of the big challenges we had was just
kind of reining ourselves in.
There was so much good material
and so much good improv on set
and the first cut we just threw it all in.
That was kind of a struggle over
the next basically eleven months
was deciding what bits to lose
and what bits to keep
because they were all great bits,
but they couldn't all coexist together.
The choices that are open to the editor
in how best to convey the story.
are limitless.